So, in the first episode of Playing with
Myself, I I promise this title is
tentative. I'm I will come up with
something better. Maybe, maybe. I don't
I don't know. But Flops couldn't quite
get there. So, we are going at it again.
Flubs versus your average table and see
if we can do better this time. We are
facing the same three decks. The Master
Mill along with Kalia. It's a typical
Kalia deck, and Bellow, but with
artifacts instead of enchantments. And I
think I'm getting better at this, but I
still made quite a few mistakes that I
caught during editing in terms of rules,
in terms of forgetting triggers or
anything else. If you catch any, please
let me know because there's a decent
chance that I missed it even after
editing and that will really help me
improve and avoid similar mistakes in
the future. All right, let's jump to the
game and see how our boy does. Playing
with myself cuz it's lonely at the top.
Okay, with no further ado, let's pick
our starting player. It's going to be
okay, the master. We draw the opening
hand. Land. Ramp. Land. Land. Okay,
looks good. We want some gas.
Oh, that is gas. But mill, please. We
want something to mill with, but I mean,
can't go wrong with this really. No.
Yeah, it doesn't get much better than
this. Okay, keep
draw
ambul. Okay, this is I like it. I like
this is a good hand because we can I
mean we don't have to Kalia if we don't
draw something big we can just hard cast
the dragon and if Kalia dies we have the
quick summer emolet back up although
none of these none of these is too safe
with flops on the field he
is fine uh draw oh another man rock okay
that's land let's hope flops doesn't get
a fast start otherwise none of this is
taking yeah meanwhile flops is trying to
do something okay okay yeah worldly
theater is sweet
snipe
Okay, this is fine. We have four lands
and uh basically Nusa here. So yeah,
this seems like a keep bellow.
Holy,
what is this?
I mean just these four cards I'm keeping
because I can drop this on turn two,
right? Right. So yeah, keep and let's
see what what else we get. Okay, blink
moth earn. Hopefully one more land. That
was a little risky. Yeah, but we're
still keeping. We're still We're going
all in, right? This is what artifact
decks do.
Great. Pass the turn. I don't mean pass
the turn. I mean uh starting the game
because we haven't played our first turn
yet. So, the master starts draw.
Good. Good. We want some mail cards, but
payoffs are also good. So, we play a
land. I think we play this as a land for
now. Yeah. Good. Pass the turn. Oh,
sorry. I played Kalias turn one already.
Wait, was No, no, no. My apologies. That
was okay. Already a misplaced. Okay, so
no draw. Play my turn one. Pass. So of
of all the decks, I only played a turn
here and didn't do anything elsewhere
and didn't even realize my apologies.
But everything should be back back in
order. Okay, flops draw
land. No rush with the tutor.
And also dreamscape artist is sweet.
Unfortunately, we don't get to play it
on turn two because we are uh we might
not be a depends. We'll see. Pass. Draw.
land into soaring.
That's a little bit dangerous, isn't it?
If so gets blown up, we are actually
stuck.
But if we don't do that,
maybe we play it safe, honestly. Cuz
maybe we can do this and next turn we
workshop into blink moth burn because no
one floss they have, you know, 20
artifact removals in the deck. So we
turn to blink earn and then they will
blow this up and we can keep the soul
ring. Right? If they have one piece, if
they have two pieces, I mean what can we
do, right? Play it safe and we see how
it goes. Untapping with the master draw.
Play a land. Uh play this land and we
ramp into tango floor. Good
pass. Kalia untaps. Draws with a land
into a signate. Yeah, we'll get a Calia
next turn probably. Pass. on top.
Draw into a land. Yeah, we're going to
get Isuza. So, we are not going to play
the artist. We're going to play Isuza
next turn and Isuza will give us two
more lands that we can use to play the
artist. Is that right? Maybe not 100%
because this land just tapped, but we do
have mana up. We have a braid. Oh, no.
We need to save 42. Yeah. So, let's pass
the turn. Bellow draws.
We uh Okay, that's interesting. We We do
need lands. Maybe we No, I think it's
still the earn. Earn is still correct.
Blink moth iron. One, two, three, four,
five for blink moth iron. Next turn, we
have two more mana from the earn. And if
we're desperate, we'll dig with Razer
Scoreboard, but for now, we're okay.
Pass. The master is like, what is
happening here? What is this start? This
is not fair. Draw. We drew a land. Nice.
Um, I think we dropped the master here,
right? That's our mill. That is our mill
engine. Yeah, let's drop our master. And
we have kind of a curve. We can ramp
later. Yeah, let's play a prismatic
vista. Pay one, get a land.
And the master. And this time I think
normally I ride myself, but this time I
think I ran Kalia just because we have
so many other pieces of reanimation.
Just getting one hit would be sweet. So
rad Kalia
and pass the turn. Cali untaps draw
removal. Let's mill one. Mill two. Okay,
nothing happens here. Actually, that's
what the master wants. So, not good for
Kalia, but let's play land. And do we
drop Kalia? I think we do. Let's drop
it. H. Yeah, might as well. Or amulet. I
think we draw Kalia. We want to drop
amulet later. So, Kalia, it kind of the
removal bait. If you have it, you have
it. If not, at least we get some free
value. So, pass the turn. We end the
turn. We're going to worldly tutor for
there's no other target. It's just or in
our case Miku.
Yeah. Solid crossover. There you go.
Miku on top. Shuffle
on top. Draw.
Play a uh Yeah, I don't know what I was
thinking. There's no way we can draw
both Miku and uh Dreamscape artist.
That's fine. Miku
pay one life
drop and uh two ends. Play land. Play
this land as well.
We are off to a great start.
Pass the turn. Hey, we survived with the
blink moth earn. Look at that. And we
hopefully top deck of land or things are
getting wonky. Oh, the one ring.
What do we even uh what do we even do?
Yeah, I think I know. So, Nexus of the
coming. So, we have one, two mana
already. 3, four, five, six mana for a
nexus of the coming
and
we enter the combat. Yes, we do. So,
enter combat and draw one. That's has a
land and uh play a razor scoreboard.
So, uh, this is actually a three three
and this card is actually exiled, but
I'm using it here to represent and when
at least play, we will, yeah, we will
remove it. Meanwhile, we got speed.
Looks like I have a lot of speed in my
decks, even though it's not the most
powerful or the most popular mechanic.
Speed one. H, draw two. Discard one,
right? Yes. Draw two. Discard. Uh, let's
discard. Uh, I don't even know what to
discard anymore. Maybe the the land.
The land is fine, though. Yeah, stone
calendar. This is not the most efficient
card.
So, we do want to play this land. And
all of a sudden, we have the one ring.
Well, look at this. Blow blow this up,
Mr. Fluffs. Uh, do we lose life? No, we
don't. Oh, we do lose two life. Yes. And
might as well use it now. Draw a card.
Lose a life. Put a ring on it.
Good turn, guys. Good turn. And clearly
right now, Bellows is the problem. And
uh let's see how people deal with us. So
master untaps
draw.
Unfortunately, we didn't get anything
that we can reanimate. But we do have
two more mill on Calia. Do we hold this?
I don't think so as per the matches
because if we mill something, the master
will take it anyways. So I think we just
ramp.
We just ramp. We just ramp. Yeah. And
hope for the best with the rad. Uh, ramp
is going to get us. We want one blue,
one black,
black here.
Blue islanding hit. Shuffle.
Boom. Here we go. Pass the turn on top
of Kalia.
Draw.
Rad one.
Rad two. Okay, we got something. master
got something. But let's see how Kalia
plays the turn first. Kalia is going to
play a land.
Honestly, at this point, I think we just
aggro into the stupid bellow. Yes. And
also, we can do a few combats. Not not
for a lot of damage, but okay. Okay,
let's do it. So, Cal um Cali attacks,
drops the Ghostban Dragon.
Oh, is that even good? It's not amazing.
I'm thinking Yeah, I'm thinking we use
waves of aggression. Might as well.
Might as well use it. Yeah. So,
everything to bellow. Oh, we can't
attack bellow. It's protected. So, let's
attack flubs then because I hate flops.
So, one, two, three, four, five, six
damage to flops. And um
yeah, waves of aggression
on tap. On top. We have nothing to drop,
which is very sad. But what can we do
again? Into flops because the master can
grab ratos to block. Actually, the
dragon can attack master because the
rats is only a three three. So, Kalia
into flips. Dragon into the master.
And yeah, the master will take it. One,
two, three, four. Meanwhile, Flops takes
two more commander damage. Okay, so we
have a gold here. This goes in the
graveyard.
And uh that's our turn. Is it? I think
so. We're going to hold this up probably
for Bellow. So meanwhile, the master at
the end of turn is going to tap. Yeah,
things are not going to get better than
this. We get a three three flying ratos
patron of chaos. Yeah, I will use this
to represent that they're dirty 33s. But
this is actually a mutant while this is
a golem. Slightly different. Pass the
turn. Hey, fluff is like what the heck
just happened? Like what? What? Why? Why
am I at 31? Look, look over there. But
we have to do something about it. Let's
draw.
Okay, so we have a few targets. We might
just have to use it. Oh, we are one mana
short, though. We want to use all three
of these. Am I selfless enough to not
play Dreamscape Artist? Absolutely not.
Do we play Flubs first then? I think
Flubs is for next turn. So, let's play a
Dreamscape artist. Is that too greedy?
I don't know if we can blow everything
up anyways. So dreamscape artist and
then we play uh attractus fall destroy
target artifact battle enchantment
creature of flying trackus fall is going
to target nexus of becoming I'm sure
that's the best one right right yes
maybe or is it blink puff no I think
it's nexus yeah let's do the nexus boom
that's it yeah we had us I think now
this is looking not like the best start
we should ah we needed more lands But
again, we already got five on turn what,
turn three. Turn four. Yeah. So, it's
not the worst.
Okay. So, yeah, we are a bit slow here,
but hopefully next turn we can start
choo chooing with the flops and pass the
turn. Okay, we kept most of our board.
This is better than expected. Bellows is
happy. Untap. Lose one life and uh yeah,
draw
one. Yes, draw one. Play a land. I think
it's I hear flips music. Do I? Yeah,
that sounds like flops.
Um, we play flips and we hold up legalis
quick reflex. So, do we have the mana
for that? We first of all, we have one,
two, three, four mana floating.
So,
so that means what that means? I think
we're going to draw cards first. Yeah,
we'll see what we can draw into first.
Draw two.
Mirror works. That's a good card. Not
what we need right now. We are a bit
stuck with our colors because this will
give us flips, but we will not have
protection up.
Without protection, I'm a little bit
concerned about our board. Although,
we're probably fine anyways. I mean, if
flips if Bellow dies,
we just cast it next turn.
Yeah, we don't have Do we Wait, wait,
wait. Sorry. I think I miscalculated.
No, I didn't. because this turns into
this and yeah so let's try it let's try
it uh boom
into bellow
and let's attempt to declare combat with
these two idiots also I forgot that we
don't need to do this because of blink
moth earn I'm sorry so let's do this and
just float the two mana sure why not we
have enough mana let's do that and let's
enter combat and this is when Kalia says
hold up I've been saving this for you.
Target battle.
It's unfortunate, but to be expected.
Yeah, we got a sweet opening hand, but
not the right colors. But still, our
follow-up is decent. One, two, three,
four, five into mirror works
and pass the turn. Yeah, that definitely
hurt, but what can we do? Pass the turn.
Kalia saves the day. Who would have
thought? Untap with the master. Sorry.
Give me a mail card. That's not a mail
card. We play a land. Oh, could the land
be this refuge? Might as well play it
because then we can Oh, but our colors
are weird. We can pass the turn. And
yeah, and hopefully Kalia gets something
else. Oh, sorry. I forgot to do this
minus one. So, there's one more rat on
the Calier. Yeah, we can also hold up
once in future in case we want to bring
back the We don't. Yeah, this is not
great. This is not great. But we do get
to draw two more cards hopefully at the
end of our turn because with Rats we are
going to target let's see target Kalia
right Kalia would have to sacrifice two
non non token permanence Kalia says no
so we draw two cards we drew
not great so we discard those discard
and uh island I guess
at least we can do this flare for free
sacking sacking this or we can do it in
response to removal right very clever
Yeah, pass the turn. Calia somehow
untapped. You can see the ones the one
time they have no disruption. We don't
draw the gaps, but maybe that's why
they're not they're not dealing with us.
So, let's draw the route and let's mill
one more. Holy crap. The master is the
master is thrilled.
Yeah.
Meanwhile, we are going to have to
punish flubs for all the crimes. So,
we're going to attack into flubs. Get a
gold token. And flubs can't do much, can
they? Yeah. Takes six. But now, everyone
can see that Kalia is out of gas. And we
do drop the puke. But who do we bog? We
bog ourselves. Is it too late? Is there
anything else for No, we don't bog
ourselves. Let's bog the master. Yeah,
we want to make our land drop.
Okay, the master gets bogged and we hold
up one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven. Nine mana. Do we drop the
signate? No rush, honestly, because what
are we going to cast? Um, yeah, let's
save it. Let's save it for now in case
the board or something comes. So, the
master then does his thing. Grabs runar
demon
who's an idiot. There's a derpy 33
flying though. And we can search for
something that we can use at instant
speed. How brilliant.
Drown in dreams. That looks solid. We
can mill for We can draw what? four and
mill someone for eight.
But it's only target player though. But
I I don't Yeah, this is the best instant
speed option. We can still do drown in
dreams in hand. Shuffle shuffle. Solid.
The turn passes to floats. Untap.
So untap. Draw.
No.
Why? This is not good.
Think we play flubs.
We have to. And we araid discarding the
gutter snipe. And next turn we can song.
Let's uprade the
mirror works.
Seems fine. Upgrade on the mirror works.
See, Kali, I'm your friend. I your
friend.
And discard snipe and pass. Next turn
will be good. I promise. Flubs. Once
again, we're digging digging. We lose
two life. Think this one ring is going
to win us the game by itself. Uh, we
draw. Yes. Oh, giggling skitter spike.
That would have been sick with a what's
it called? Mirror works. So, but now we
we still just uh draw three. Yeah, why
not draw three?
We got colored land. We play that.
Sorry. We play that from hand. This is
our hand. And we got a chromos memorial.
We are cooking. I the Ugan will be
amazing as well. So the plan here, I
think we drop Ugan first. So we added
one, two, three,
four mana. Now we need two more for the
ugene. Let's drop the Eugene. And
everything now costs two less.
So then can we float this term? I think
that should be our primary goal, right?
So, one, two, three,
four,
four mana.
No, we don't have the mana. We don't
have the mana.
So, unfortunately, we're going to have
to settle for
waiting at one turn.
We're going to drop our giggling skitter
spike for one, two. It's only It's only
two mana. Yo, artifacts are so cheap.
But flips is so expensive.
Yeah, for two mana we're dropping this.
Then with Uin, we are going to destroy
something. That something is going to be
That's tough. I mean, Kala is pressuring
us, but they haven't dropped anything
on his board. Is looking like the
master.
The master is getting so much value. So,
yeah, let's blow up the master.
And we saved mana to monstrous to
monstrous are scaring spike. Not the
faster turn, but next turn we'll be
good. Well, the master gets to Well, the
master is gone, but ah, my apologies. I
forgot to do one thing. In response to
the master dying, we're going to draw in
dreams because then we can mill and draw
at the same time. We're going to draw
four cards. Four cards. That correct?
Yes. Meanwhile, we mill our best friend
Kalia for eight.
One, two, three, four, five. Brilliant.
Six, seven. Holy craps. Uh, okay. Eight.
That is a good eight. That is a good
eight. So, on top. Sorry about the
misplay, but instance are difficult. On
top, draw
reanimate. Okay, we are getting the
whole package then. Um, what's the
graveyard looking like? There's no
graveyard. No, no creature here, I
believe. But we still do it. We still do
it. What we do is
reanimate into
this the mophosm. Let's see what's in uh
fluff graveyard.
Nope, there's nothing. Yeah, let's
reanimate
into meoplasm. So, first reanimate um
yeah reanimate targeting
rasath seems like a good target. So,
rascath hold up one second.
Rascath is a good target.
No, maybe. Yeah, it's fine. Okay, so we
lose eight life.
At the same time, we are going to the
minimum plasmant on Valkoth.
Let's pay the mana first. One, two,
three, four. You know what? You know
what I'm thinking? We should just hold.
We should do instant speed everything
with Alchemist Refuge. That's how good
refuge is because then we can we still
have five mana so we can reanimate and
we can uh espress the magic.
Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. I I will do that. I
will do that because that's so powerful
and yeah and we have a decent board
already. A lot of the removals in this
game especially flops is sorcery speed.
So we want to hold. I think that's the
best play. So we discard and pass. Uh
well, first we have to do this. Ratal's
targeting once again Kalia. We will draw
two cards. We love Calia so much. So
we're keeping one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven. Are we keeping a land?
I guess we keep a land instead of flare.
I don't think we have a window to cast
flare anymore. So let's keep this. At
least it can be a spell. Sorry about the
confusion of the mess here. Um here is
the seven I'm keeping. We're going to
discard
and pass. At this point, Kali is
considering, do we route? I don't think
so. We don't kill enough. Yeah, we are
really stuck. We need I mean, we got all
the good stuff got mil. It's going to be
used by the master instead of ourselves.
So, I think we just hope route and use
our dragon. Oh, we got this dragon.
That's a good dragon. But again, we are
not really short on mana. We're short on
gas.
Also, I just remembered one thing. I
should use dice to keep track of how
many times I've cast a commander, even
if they're not in the command zone. I
will do that now. I'm trying to improve,
trying to get better at the
representation of things, but there are
definitely problems. Please let me know
if there's something you want me to fix.
But with this board, I think the best
way is to drop drop quicksilver amulet
and try to instant speed our ancient
copper dragon. So that's that. So amulet
and meanwhile we are going to attack
into somebody probably bellow again. Oh.
So this one into Ugan, this one into
bellow. And we are doing our part, my
friends. We are doing our part. So Bella
will take four and Ugan is dead.
Meanwhile, we make one more treasure.
This is a very strange game for Talia.
Pass. Also an awkward game for flips.
I'm tempted to discard song creation.
It's so good. But but
okay.
I starting to think we discard the song.
Yeah. Yeah, discard the song
unfortunately. But this is the correct
play, I'm pretty sure. because then we
can activate dreamscape artist and get
two lands. So we sacrifice one land here
and we get two lands and then we can
start our chain again. Hopefully drop
more lands. Now we are very behind. We
are not in a place where we can answer
things but hopefully we can set up for
one turn or maybe two turns and then we
can start doing things. Hopefully they
can fight fight fight it out for once.
The Cali is doing okay and the master is
it's fine. So
yeah leeching off of the the ones with a
head start. Uh let's get forest. That's
fine. Let's get a This deck has a total
of seven basics. I have to be careful,
but I don't think we are close to
running out yet
and play a land. First land draw. Second
land draw. Cyberman conversion.
Let's convert. Who do we convert?
Let's target creature face. Um I guess
the I mean Cali had Cali hasn't dropped
anything for for three turns. So I think
we leave her. Let's convert the glitter
glittering glitter spike. And meanwhile,
Bellow has to think about this. I think
it's fine. I mean, it's a cool card, but
we have to save this protection for
Bellow, right? Look at all these
powerful things we have in hand. So,
it's fine. Let's
untap this. Oh, sorry. Let's flip this.
It's a two two Cyberman. And uh let's
draw Punkifi. I mean, rapid
hybridization. We hybridize. Who? We
hybridize.
We're still going for Bellow. Bellow is
just pretty far ahead right now. So, we
hybridize this stupid thing. Doesn't do
that much though.
Maybe the Ratoss. Maybe the Calia. No,
we're still we're still against Tibello.
So, boom.
This is exiled.
Congratulations. We turned your 3- three
into although it's really a useless 33,
but it's an artifact, so it can become
useful once spells is on the on the
field. Unfortunately, we couldn't find
the right token. We the frog lizard. We
found an ape. This could be relevant
because there's total virus in this
deck, but it probably won't be. Probably
won't be. Yeah. So, let's draw our
second card. Third, sorry. Our next
card. Nous revival. That's a good card.
We revive what? We revive. Oh, Song of
Creation.
Yo, that's good. But then if we revive
it, if we revive it, one second.
Then next turn we will have two cards in
hand. How about we have the overall?
Okay, we are set. Okay, let's hold this
and not play anything else, right? Is
that correct? No, I think it's fine. I
think we can keep playing.
Yeah, because we can then draw one more
card, right? So, no rival paying paying
life and targeting the song of creation.
Meanwhile, we draw a card. Yeah, that's
our third land. So, this is on top. Play
our third land. The song is in our hand.
Okay. Do we play the song? I don't think
uh
if we draw another land, this is really
good, but I think we wait till next turn
for Yeah, I think we wait till next
turn. Let's do that. Pass. Okay, Bellow
has all this mana for what?
Oh, I guess we can uh we can create a
power stone. Let's use our hall of tanks
and
tap.
It's called power stone. Yes. Okay.
Okay, I couldn't find a power stone
token. So, this will do. It's drawn
power stone tapped, but it untaps with
the board. So, we untap
and lose three life to our one ring. We
have to finish the game fast if we're
going to finish it at all. So, uh first
we add one, two, three. Is this an
artifact? Yes, it is. Four, five, six,
right? No, five. Yes, five mana. with
the five mana. We're going to play uh
no, we're going to
use the firewood thicket and this as
mana source to make red and green. So,
we have four mana left and we're going
to cast bellow. And bellow costs
uh five total. We've got sorry, five
minus one. So, we've got one left, one
floating. And with the one floating,
we're not going to waste any time. We're
going to just f the workshop.
One, two, three,
four, five, six, seven. Take two
and drop a cornos memorial. Just like
that.
What are you going to do about it,
people? We don't have enough mana for
shamanic revelation, which would be
really nice, but I mean, we can draw
into more mana, maybe. So, let's see. We
attack with everything because flying
vigilance, uh, the damage can be kind of
evenly split. Let's make it kind of
even. Although, we do know the what's it
called? The master has a lot of mana
open. But, I mean, we have pro black.
How afraid are we? Not really. I mean,
we can send the instru.
What else can go? The ape can go. Seems
fair. Meanwhile, the important ones will
go at Kalia because Oh, wait. No, Cali
can drop blockers, too. One second. Hold
up. Okay, so unless Kalia drops an angel
and we still have Chaos Work, we are
fine.
So, yeah. Oh, let's let's leave do we
leave flops alone? I don't want to leave
flops alone. Okay, let's do this. Across
Memor Memorial into flops and these two.
So, in terms of importance, this is the
least the most important go into flops.
These two go into Kalia and everything
else goes into the master. The master is
thinking, let's see the graveyards
again. We can grab demons, but they're
not going to help us block. We can grab
this dragon, which will help us block,
but then we miss out on one of these
demons. Is that worth it?
I want to say maybe. Yeah, we can
reanimate the dragon to block one of
them. We can also mimoplasm. I think we
take it because then we can surprise
uh Valavoth and just link some life,
right? So, I think I think we're fine
for now. Even if we get the dragon, we
we don't want to risk it dying, right?
We we want to get our little dragons out
to make the tokens. So, I think we take
it. So, the master takes 4 plus 3 plus
two. That's nine.
Ouch. Do we route? Sorry, I should have
thought about this earlier, but I'm
tempted. I'm tempted. Everything on that
side has indestructible, right? So,
yeah, I think I think we're fine. We're
at 39 life, so let's take it. We take
the three plus four,
also not doing commander damage. It's
probably not relevant. And flubs flops
will take the damage, of course. Take
four.
Okay, this is a good turn for Bellow. We
are drawing. We've hit with one, two,
three. Draw three cards. Is that right?
Yeah. No one blocked. So draw three.
We get to play a land. The land will be
this one. It's going to be the green
side. Yes.
And do we play anything else? We can
hold this for card draw. We hold our our
chaos working pass. Okay. This is the
master's music flash. At the end of
turn, we're going to reanimate
uh Razakv, I believe, is the correct.
Yes, Razakov
and
uh Lucate life. Okay.
Hold up. Is Razakth correct?
I still think it is. Yeah, I think it is
because then we can
Did we pay mana? We didn't. Sorry. Pay
for reanimate. Then we can sacrifice a
thing like this. This is uh I believe
ghost in the graveyard, right? Yes.
Ghost. So, we go down to eight life. We
need lifelink now. But we get to our
entire deck for anything four mana or
less and we can just do it right now.
And something that can get us Valkoth
would be sweet. Arcane Heist is also
really good because I can cast it now.
Oh, never mind. I don't have the colors.
No. Although I can still cast it on my
opponent or on my turn. Let's see.
Because
if there's something really good in the
graveyards, we can use it. Uh, one
second. Let's take a look at graveyards
first. Thinking cap on. We can get
ruinous. Okay, so this alone is worth
it. Yeah, this alone is worth it. We get
this.
Oh, but then we don't get a lifelink.
Eight life is risky, but we can take
some risks, right? So, espress to match.
Oh, no, no, no. We don't use this.
Oh,
slight mistake. Slight mistake. I think
we use once and future to return two
cards to our hand.
Yeah,
one of them will reanimate although we
have to be very careful with that. And
uh the other one will be
I guess drown in dreams is fine or get a
land.
drown uh flare of cultivation
because we don't want to drop a land for
three life. So what we're going to do
now is we're just going to straight up
use it and oh this is exiled once in
future. We're going to straight up get
the ramp
get two basics
island. Now we were short on blue
sources.
Does anyone want to do anything with
this board?
I think no because killing these two. I
mean, Kalia can route. Meanwhile, Bellow
can chaos orb,
but I think yeah, I'm not I think it's
too late at this point. We just see what
happens. And hopefully we find a window
to strike and kill this person at eight
life. So, let's untap.
Whoops.
And uh we draw for turn.
So our first play will be to straight up
arcane heist. Is that a good play? That
sounds like a pretty good play.
Yeah, we desperately need life, but
blowing up everything seems decent. So
Arcane Heist one, two, three, four, and
we will attempt to target the ruinous
ultimatum. Kalia, what do you say?
I think we route at this point because
otherwise otherwise they will cipher,
right? And then we'll get another spell.
So I think we just route.
Yeah, that seems correct. And we're
losing our treasures anyways, right? So
1 2 3 4 5 six seven. Yeah, we are the
first to respond casting route on top of
the runest ultimatum or this is the
stack. We'll figure it out. And also
yeah, this is fine. I should order it
better like this.
Okay, flops is is sad, but we are not
screwed because of the song in our hand.
So, yeah, no responses. I guess we let
Bella respond. Uh, draw four.
Put a ring on it. Draw four. One, two,
three, four. Yeah, there's a lot we can
do here. So, um, we still hold up chaos.
Do we use it now? I don't think so. I
think we can wait. So, we lose the this
thing. Yeah, in the graveyard lose the
ape
and we lose our commander which will
cost seven mana. Everything else stays.
Okay, now we have a question for the
master. Do we do one more tutor? I think
we do. We do. Yeah, it's just two I mean
three two life, right? Yeah, two life is
too too good to pass up on even when we
are at eight life. So, sorry here. It's
got something that can gain us life. And
again, it's it's just um
right
and with the board right now and the
board is being cleared. So, we're just
worried about Bellow. That's it. And
Bellow is not really great at removing
things. Vgovoth is pretty safe against
spot removals, right? So, I don't see
too much.
Uh what's it called? Breach.
Um, yeah, we don't have enough mana for
that. We can do it for just a soaring
just to just to get a bump in mana. I
think that's not the worst idea. Or we
for something for later on, but I do
think getting that mana boost is helpful
or this as a win condition later on.
They a little bit too because we do have
a one-two punch here. We can use this to
middle half the library and we can use
this to win. Also, this will help us
stabilize, right? So yeah, we need to
finish fast even with Algavoth. So let's
do this. Let's t for the monument.
Yeah, the middle plan seems good. And at
the same time, we're gonna
Okay, we're done tutoring. So then the
stack resolves. So everything gets blown
up. Kalia gone.
Dragon gone. Amulet gone.
Uh Razak is gone.
On this side, we lose these. Flubs is
sad.
We lose
everything.
Unfortunate
power stone soaring.
That's the board.
Can we kill someone?
We are at six life. But if we
uh can we do 19 I don't think we can do
19 damage here. Isn't anything big
enough?
Yeah, Vaboth is still correct. All
right, Vaga. Voga. Voga. Let's go. So,
grab this with the mimoplasm.
Uh, melasm is vagaboth is actually
exiled, but just a representation. And
we exile something big here.
Uh, we might need it more than Razak.
Let me let me think about that again.
Okay, Ratos can't go. We This is what we
really don't need.
That means six counters on our goof.
Hopefully we get a swing on this empty
board. Pass the turn. Kalia is quite sad
to say the least. Uh we are going to
draw farewell but I guess we are saving
up for farewell or the dragon next turn
or John sign pass the turn. Yeah, this
game has been rough for Calia. It's just
kind of giving gas to the master. That's
the entire purpose. We draw
sum of creation.
Do we flops? question. I think we do.
Oh, wait. If we flubs, we draw
two cards on the two in the two cards.
We have to hope for No, I think we play
normally. I think we we skip flops for
now. So, land land into fire incription.
The ring temps me. I don't think it's
relevant here. We don't have creature.
So, we draw two cards.
We play uh sore ring.
Draw two more cards.
Um, we play a land. That's our first
land.
And do No, we cannot hold anything
because the song. So, we play a Burgie.
Draw two more cards. Hopefully, one more
land. We got one more land. And the land
is going to be tapped because we can't
cast anything. Yeah, this is a solid
setup turn. We're at 25 life, so it's
not looking too bad. Discard pass. Okay.
Bellow with a sweet start, but now
feeling the burden of the ring. Lose
one, two, three, four life on top.
shouldn't use that chaos work. Maybe we
should have used that chaos word. But
what target? I can't think of a target.
Oh, maybe we should have targeted the
one ring. Maybe. Maybe.
Okay, so now we have a problem. The
problem is we cannot die to Valoth,
which is 15
15 power. And right now our plan, I
guess, is to chaos warp it so that we
can sacrifice three permanence, which
includes this. But three permanence is a
lot of permanence and we don't have that
much to stack.
I think we just have to Yeah, that's our
only game plan. We We are desperate. So,
we are going to semblance of anvil.
Let's go. Actually, no. Sorry. First,
we're going to draw some cards.
One last
protection spell
lands.
Okay. No, we don't lose life. We just
get a ring counter, a burden counter.
And um yeah, let's play the
semblance info to exile.
I don't think we need.
So maybe this cuz it costs more. This
can also exile the one ring, but I think
we're on the chaos war plan. So this is
exiled.
And
now what if the Valoth doesn't attack
us, right? It's probably this. Yeah,
let's not be too greedy here. We are
desperate. So the one what's it called?
The Wonder Worers Crucible has been
exiled. And we
uh yeah, we we pay mana for things. We
pay two life and two mana for
um mystic forge. And we need just one
more permanent. Oh, we have three
permanents now. But we want to keep this
on the board, right? So, let's uh Yeah.
Oh, we don't have enough mana then, do
we? Oh, are we one short? That's just so
awkward.
Did we play a land?
I don't think so. I don't remember
playing a land. So, let's do that. If if
I mess up here, I apologize, but I think
we're fine. So, now we have enough just
enough to three, one, two, three for the
banner of kingship. Yeah. But then it's
sad because we are the target for sure,
right? For Vas our board. What can we
do? What can we do?
Pass the turn. Okay. Meanwhile, Valgoth
is staring down Bellow like, what is
happening over here? I don't know. But
we untap with lots of mana and a solid
board. Yeah, cannot ask for too much
more. So, we draw,
play a land. We can even untap our
Valkoth to block with. That's sweet.
Um, let's see. Okay, I think we attack
Bellow.
Yes, this happens.
And Bellow will do the plan. We're going
to use Chaos Warp to target the Mia
Posasm
here. And do we allow the sacrifice
trigger to happen?
If we can remove two things,
right? But I don't think there's a like
we can we can espec for for the demon
the deer demon
but I don't think because this deck is
built to rely on other people's decks. I
don't think we have something that can
remove two permanence. We do have uh we
have cyclonic grift but this is four
mana for espers and we have six mana
here. Oh no so close. What do we do?
Yeah, I think has to go. Okay, let's let
the sacrifice happen first. So what
happens is these are all sacrificed but
they're actually exiled under Valkaboth
under the mimoplasm. So one, two, three,
like this.
Oh, but then
I get one ring. I get one ring. So we
flash with this and we pay life, right?
Just to make sure I'm reading it
correctly. Yes, we pay life to cast
this. Pay four life. Oh, wait. But we go
down to two
and fluffs can burn us with the fiery
inscription. Not on not on this their
turn, but they just need one spell on
our upkeep to burn us down.
Whoops. That might not be the best play.
Can we protect ourselves from Flops? We
can kill the inscription because flops
is pretty light on wind condition. So if
we kill the inscription, we're probably
fine. Yeah, we should be able to find a
way to deal with the the enchantment,
right?
Yes, I think so. I think so. Yeah. Well,
let's get the protection for a turn.
Might might be stupid, but and also we
get a chaos. Who knows what we'll get.
So, let's lose four life. Pay four life
into this. Oh, and also because we can
now reanimate with no consequence. Yeah,
we are fine. We are fine. Okay, so let's
uh do this. Oh, this is shuffled into
No, this is exiled. Sorry. These are all
exiled. This is exiled because it's the
Moplasm. And let's shuffle the melasm
into our deck. This is an important
shuffle. Chaos work here.
Uh, shuffle. Let's cut. Um, sure. Cut
here.
And
the water crystal. Interesting. Does
that do anything here? Not too much. Not
too much. Yeah, we can. Yeah, we can let
all this happen. Okay, everything
happens. Then we are going to
reanimate.
Reanimate what? Reanimate.
It's been a difficult game for Calia.
Do we get the ghost dragon for some
mana? No.
Ancient goat dragon tyrant.
We just need life gain. So, I think
ruins card demon. Yeah, let's to for
something
that can deal with the enchantment
there.
Unfortunately, looks like our best play
here is to memory plunder
and um
yeah, to memory plunder and a removal
spell to deal with the inscription.
Do we do it now? I think we're fine. I
think we can wait because yeah, we are
protected until the next turn, right?
So, let's t for that. Put in our hands.
So, we have some options. Do we play
something else? No, we're fine. We're
fine. Let's keep this board. Pass the
turn. Calia draw.
Oh, we are at 32 life. Do we farewell on
this board? I don't think we do just
because
we are not a threat to anyone at the
moment. And we want fluffs to kill the
master.
And uh yeah, Embell is not doing
anything anymore. So I think we we uh or
maybe we play ancient copper dragon and
go for the greed, right? If we hit, we
hit big. Do we hit big? No, I think we
dig. We have to dig for something.
Namely, sneak attack. Yeah. So horror.
Let's play the horror or the doom
whisperer and keep this man up and pass
the turn.
Okay. Flubs is seeing this and going,
"Holy crap.
We can do a lot here. We can't I don't
think we can kill Calia. Maybe even we
can kill Calia with the Burgie. Maybe
maybe it's been a misplay by Kalia, but
we'll see. So, we draw a top. Nice.
So, float one colorless. Play a top. We
should use Oh, this is going to get
complicated. I'll use this to keep track
of mana. So, we've got one red mana. I
will try to use it as soon as possible.
We'll draw two here. Or do we?
Yeah, we draw two. I don't think we need
floods anymore.
Um, play our first land of the turn.
We use our red and blue to play
sorcerers class.
That's super good. Make red mana. Now,
to level this up all the way, we need
um we need how much mana? We need two
plus one. So, we have two here. Two
more. And so, we need seven more mana.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
I don't believe it's worth it. don't
think we'll be doing enough damage,
especially when we can't even touch
maybe or touch the master. Sorry. So,
yeah, let's just play it. Um, we draw
two first from playing it. Then we draw
two and discard two. At this point, I
think we can discard some lands.
Yeah.
Okay. So, then we we have the one red
floating. We are going to keep these
two. And yeah, I think it's worth it.
Stormclan artist. So far, we haven't
done any damage, but we are setting up
pretty well. One, two,
three, four.
Storm clan artist.
At this point, I think the masters needs
to think, do we do anything against
this? I don't think so.
Do we have something we can use here to
destroy? I don't think so. Deadly relic
route. Oh, maybe we need to route. But
if we route, we're dead to this
bellow. Chaos work.
Yeah, the options are very limited. So
unfortunately, we have to watch flubs do
its thing. So then we get one more this
and draw two more.
Okay, we are going to rack up some
damage here. So we find some prisoners
against
target artifact.
There's no target.
So for once we are going to exile the
top three cards of someone's library and
we can use it. So we use one red here
and we use a land but then we create one
red mana and a treasure. Yeah, we got
our storm pieces. So we do prisoner and
everyone takes two. Uh then we are going
to choose is it Kalia? I think Kalia has
the most generically useful stuff but
the master if we get something that can
grade dig. Yeah, I'm going to choose the
master actually because we can dig. We
can use Kali's grave. Now, imagine
getting the gold spend dragon with this
on the field. We are the game's over.
Over. So, the master will give us the
top three cards exiled. We'll put here.
Uh, no. Nothing good. Nothing good. So,
that's that. And we are going to
use our mana here. Use our mana.
Resculpt. Resculpt. Targeting
the one ring. Uh, that that doesn't do
anything. targeting
maybe just to screw over Kalia. Yeah,
let's make sure Kalia is dead. Dead.
Yeah, Kalia has no no chance of coming
back. So, at this point, Kalia is really
regretting the decisions at this point.
At this point, Kalia is regretting the
decisions. Yeah, we messed up a little
bit here. So, let's do Whisper a bit.
I'm not sure what we're looking for
anymore. Uh, yeah.
Two.
Four. Desperation. Six.
Eight.
Maybe this
not really. 10.
12.
14.
Yeah. 16.
18.
Casty. No. 20. Let's take for maybe two
more just in case. We got this. So
that's what we're going to keep. Somehow
if we live till the next turn, we will
we will live till the next next turn.
Good plan. Uh, so we lost the 20 life
here, right?
And all we get is this lousy elemental
token. Okay, so we've got the mana,
sorry, the mana, one mana, and one
treasure as usual.
And now the master has to think, do we
allow fluffs to kill everyone? So let's
play one, two, three,
four, leaving us with two green mana.
Right. Tapping uh memory plunder.
Although I just realized I forgot
something is that flops cannot keep
cards in their hand. But then Philips
has the top. So they can always Yeah. So
it doesn't change anything. Okay.
Plunder.
Let's memory plunder for
Yeah. Tries his fall and kill the
enchantment. That is fiery thing.
Something fiery inscriptions
that happens. And honestly, I'm not sure
we saved them because flubs can just
keep digging, right? Uh but it's the
best we can do at this moment. So, okay.
So, this is where we draw two cards
and we pay one fortune teller's talent.
Doesn't do much, but it's one mana. We
get one red here.
And uh we draw two more cards.
Okay, we are down.
So right now we can for each mana we
make we can embrace the unknown ones to
dig for another damage source but I'm
not sure we have enough mana. So I think
we're better off digging with these
anyways. Yeah we want spell quantity. So
where down
let's do it. We are going to target
um the the water crystal.
Sure the water crystal
happens.
We used one mana here which we get back
and yeah so cost no mana basically draw
two.
Okay we got Valica exploration and a
psychonic rift. The rift is good but
doesn't win us the game.
Valica exploration can do damage but not
in the way we want against
against our master deck. So let's
continue to cycle through. Druid class
draw two
collective uh collective resistance
blowing up the semblance anvil.
Whoops.
We are starting to run out of targets
which is awkward. Shot two. So our
second left return I believe this is so
in life personal tutor does not do
anything. We will see. Personal tutor
pay one here, but we get one treasure
back and we get three red. Personal
tutor, we need to find a way to kill the
mopplasm. Actually, we need to kill
everyone.
Can we net some mana?
Oh, I know.
Snap. Snap. Do it. If we snap, do we
have enough mana to level up sorcerers
class? We can tap one. One, two, three,
four,
five, six, seven.
Yeah, I like that. Let's try it. Let's
try it. I think it's Oh, we can't t for
snap. Ah,
we t for
something
to do damage. Do we have still have a
mystical tutor in here? Not. Oh, we do.
So, we personal t for the mystical
tutor.
Yeah. Okay. I think we have a plan. So
the plan here is we Okay, we Sorry. So
this is in the deck actually. So we draw
two first,
right? And then we use
this and this to level it up to level
three.
And now every spell we cast is boom. So
we cyclonic rift something. We rift the
um the the the the demon I guess. Yeah.
Not super the wine ring, I guess.
So then the master will use it to draw a
card because why not? Okay, the win ring
is back in club's hand. Yeah, I think we
we're killing this turn. Pretty pretty
confident about that. Um yeah, so we are
back to mana. Mana. Yeah, then we draw
two cards
and we mystical tutor.
Now we have to do some quick maths. How
many instance or sorceries have we cast
this turn? We have cast 1 2 3 4
5 6 7. Yeah. So, we're just dealing
seven damage. Um or eight damage
actually if we cast our mystical tutor.
Oh, no. We casted Oh, sorry. Yeah, we
cast a psychonautic rift that dealt
eight damage.
The game seems pretty over now. We
missed Goutor
and the game is Yeah. And our opponents
are dead. We use this mana.
Okay. Boom. Boom. Boom. Also, I forgot
something important because the speed
here should actually be three, I
believe, because we attack twice. But
everything else seems accurate. We our
game is over for Bellow and for Kalia.
Probably should have farewell, but don't
think we win anyways because we're not
really progressing the game at all. Um,
so, okay. So now we use our one extra
mana just to spin top just to see.
Oh, my apologies. We're supposed to draw
two first and then the tutor happens,
right? Then we spend time.
Okay. So then we draw two and the tutor
happens.
Yes, we get snap.
Can Snap target our own creature? I'm
pretty sure it can. Otherwise, that
would be a problem.
Snap. Yes, I can target my own card.
What a broken instant. So, snap is on
top.
And we're going to spin top because to
be safe, we want two spells on top. We
want two spells on top.
And yeah, so let's use one red to spin
over snap or to spin top. Okay, we got
two instance on top. That is very good.
Yeah, that's our turn. Okay, so the
master untaps.
I believe before we draw, Philips is
going to try to shoot some damage this
way. I realize I'm sorry, I have to
discard my hand first. Realize I made a
pretty big punt because this only deals
one damage now and the master is at two
life. So if I didn't have two spells,
this wouldn't even happen. So we flip
top.
All right, we draw the snap. Sorry, like
this.
I guess the snap will target Burgie. No,
this feels bad. But yeah, that was a bit
of a blunder. Hopefully, we don't get
punished too hard. So, snap targets
Burgie. Pay two. We lose one life. And
now there's a window before we draw,
before we get the mana for the master to
respond. And also one damage on the
stack. The master is going to flash.
And we have uh we can mill. How much can
we mill for? We can mill for
the library. It's not a nothing.
Um let's see our graveyard real quick.
There is nothing here. Unfortunately, we
no longer have a graveyard to work with.
Yeah. So, let's take a look at flubs.
And we no longer have Calia is what I
meant. Uh, we can get a creature from
here that could help us, but probably
not.
H
I think we are at our wiz end here.
Yeah, I think.
Yeah, even with flash, what can we do?
Can we Yeah, if we have Kali's grave, we
can do something. But
okay, so this happens.
Um,
make a treasure, make a mana, draw two
cards.
Burgie comes back on top two lands. This
and this, I guess. And uh, we use a
reality shift
on the It has to be It has to be a
creature. So on the storm clan artist.
And then we get one more treasure.
Oh, we should have used the treasure.
So, the L is not tapped. So, we use
that. And the target here. So, we then
get a treasure. And we draw two cards.
Still no response from the master. And
the game seems to be over.
That's all. Okay. Good games.
Good game.
Okay, so we did it. Yeah, Flopups
somehow did it. This game, if nothing
else, showcases the power of Song of
Creation, and I've always wanted to
build a deck for Song, and Flops is just
perfect. And this concludes our Flub
series. We will bring another exciting
commander in with a set of three new
opponents. And once again, I do think
I'm getting better with every video with
the filming and trying to manage all the
interactions and triggers. Uh, again, a
lot of errors, but I feel like we did
better than the first video. In the next
one, I'm confident there will be more
improvements. Hopefully, one day I can
make a video with where people struggle
to find rules mistakes. And when that
happens, wow, I will be the biggest nerd
of you all. Just you wait. So, thanks
for watching. If you enjoy this series,
please like and subscribe. There will be
more. and I'll see you.